[Musique]
je suis candidat on fait pour redonner à
la france sa liberté son indépendance et
la débarrasser de la corruption des
conflits d'intérêts des lobbys des
sociétés secrètes qui la grangrène ainsi
que de l'union européenne qui nous fait
perdre notre souveraineté et notre
démocratie
juste la découverte de lieux prg été
dégoûtés par la politique française tous
partis confondus
j'étais un abstentionniste et je ne
pensais plus que je pourrai un jour
connaître un parti intègre qui dit la
vérité aux français et qui représente
vraiment le peuple
[Musique]
j'ai fait cinq points différents le
premier ça serait la défense d'une
démocratie plus directe en faisant appel
au référendum sur les questions
importantes telles que leclerc
l'immigration la bête jeu proposera
également un véritable référendum
d'initiative citoyenne ou populaire avec
un seuil de déclenchement de cinq cent
mille signatures soit à peu près 1,5
pour cent du corps électoral
la deuxième idée elle est très
importante c'est l'assainissement de la
classe politique française par
l'inéligibilité à vie de tout élu
condamné dans les acides dans l'exercice
de ses fonctions
je demanderai également l'obligation
pour tous les élus ou membres de
l'exécutif de procéder à casier
judiciaire vierge
ce qui paraît un minimum plus vu qu'on
demande pour beaucoup d'autres
professions je lancerai aussi un
référendum pour demander aux français
s'ils souhaitent le maintien de la
france dans l'union européenne
je proposerai aux français le lancement
de la procédure de disques de
destitution de macros pour violations
répétées de la constitution
j'ai une cinquième idées phares je
proposerai la reconnaissance pleine et
entière du vote blanc il sera un
révocatoire
[Musique]
les habits d'un souvenir parce que je
représente le seul parti qui soit
vraiment d'opposition en france
les autres partis de l'extrême droite à
l'extrême gauche ne sont que de fausses
l'opposition ou des oppositions contrôle
et vous aurez avec moi l'occasion de
donner votre voix à un candidat qui aime
la france et les français et qui se
placera en véritables opposants à
maquereau qui a été mis en place par les
médias et les puissances financières
pour des frais la france est violente et
les français donc j'appelle tous les
dégoûtés de la politique les
abstentionnistes à découvrir notre
mouvement de libération nationale et à
me soutenir en allant voter avec l'upm
votre loi aura enfin de l'importance